and here i am with us number one knock
more of course a favorite with st. Louis
fans but today we were a little worried
at what point were you most worried oh
wow just wasn't very good opening I mean
when I play this f3 f4 I probably should
have done something more double edged
perhaps and I should gone for g4 or
something but with the way I played I
was just worse and pretty much I
basically tried to trick maxium by going
a five and managed to work but uh wasn't
wasn't pretty at anyway and what about
you what are your advice I know you grew
up playing lots of bullet and blitz
chess and still often do do you advise
that for the young kids here at the
London chess classic I mean it's a good
tool for recognizing patterns I think in
general whether it's blitz or it's just
a normal shots I think really it's very
important just play as much you can so
you have a better pattern recognition
but that being said there are many
different approaches and what worked for
me certainly would not work for other
people so I think it just depends on the
person much more than then you know any
sort of concrete you know
straightforward advice it depends on the
person how they how they study and learn
learn best so it's very much up to the
individual is there any rating threshold
where you feel like bullet is useful
like a 1400 player playing bullet might
be too fast you have any opinions like
that i mean i think bolin and blitz both
i think up to maybe twenty-two
twenty-three hundred it's very
beneficial and after that it's it's not
beneficial at any rate but i think just
in general there's there's no drawback
at the lower level so I I don't see any
reason to advise slightly weaker players
to not to not you know play blitz and
Bullock's I think it can only help
account her all right great there you
have it play one minute until tomorrow
right tomorrow's game with macklemore
here and wrapping up round two of the
London chess classic